greetings out there in podcast land
you're listening to yet another podcast
this one is brought to you by bud light
celta we used to talk about them all the
time finally they just said okay we'll
sponsor your show as long as you don't
do an annoying intro with an annoying
old-timey voice it's a deal i said
here's the show
[Music]
in the summer of 2005 i went to chicago
illinois to shoot a movie called the
breakup one point we were doing a scene
tons of people around most of whom were
extras but there were a lot of passerbys
and um passerbys
i always have trouble with that pastor i
never know if it's passersby or pass or
buys i think it's passersby passersby it
just sounds weird it's always a password
there are a lot of pastors buys passing
by the point of the story is that i was
wearing a um it was the end of the movie
the original ending they shot another
ending but the original ending john
michael higgins uh who is part of an
acapella group and called the tone
rangers and he and his group are dressed
as tacky looking gosh cowboys with
sequins and like sparkles and stuff and
i emerge from their group dressed as
tanto from the lone ranger
as they're dressed in tacky
version of cowboy outfit i'm dressed in
the tacky version of the native american
outfit very offensive i remember waiting
in between while they were setting up
and i remember saying my friend john
passani
i kind of commented that they were
recognizing me because there all these
people were like taking photos and as
they were passing by and pointing at me
and
and he said yeah or it might have
something to do with the fact that
you're just wearing a loincloth and a
like a feather in your hair i had i was
practically naked except for this little
skimpy offensive native american you're
lucky you didn't shoot that last year oh
you would have been cancelled oh yeah
quickly life could be a dream life could
be a dream
you're listening to life is short i am
your far more woke host justin long life
could be a dream
with me as always is in the process of
waking up i'm a stir
yeah you're stirring
christian we're we're coming to learn
that like you know we just didn't grow
up with
certain sensitivities that we that are
important now yes the way the uh native
americans were treated at the
dawn of this country was uh really
disgusting and terrible yeah read bury
my heart a wounded knee and uh you'll
know uh but at the time
yeah just weren't sensitive to it and
this was an outfit that i was wearing
that i totally forgot i was wearing
but it was a different time
it was a different time it was a
different time and the point
was that we were making fun of the
appropriation of it right it's clearly a
joke
i get why people are offended by it but
to defend it for a second it was a joke
yeah in a very obvious joke very obvious
that the outfit was so over the top you
know who should be upset by it cowboys
acapella singers oh yeah
yeah i asked you in fact if you were
offended by that what did i say uh
at the time i was i think currently in
october i think you were in 2005. you
were
in well we don't have to go into it but
everyone knows that you were in a band
no the country knows and uh yeah were
you offended by that because they kind
of make fun of acapella in that kind of
make fun of it they make completely make
fun of yeah i wasn't offended because i
think a lot of acapella music
is uh deserves to be made fun of not the
music itself but the people who do it
well that's the thing that's the
difference between like native americans
they take themselves very seriously
often from my experience
they are they're ripe for uh satire
whereas native americans
are the last people that deserve to be
made fun of it right it's um
and again i don't just the defense again
i don't think we were making fun of
native americans uh it was the tackiness
of that of our appropriation the joke
was that the group was named the tone
rangers it was all awesome it was a play
on lone ray yeah which had a character
named tanto right um it's just
circumstantial but really they're making
fun of acapella singers again i can
understand why seeing that image would
also be offensive so why are we talking
about this well our guest today is very
offensive no our guest today is a big
acapella fan yeah oh my god no i think
he'd be uh the opposite of that maybe be
like are you [ __ ] kidding me
i had to guess i would say he's not an
acapella no but he is
so our guest today is jake johnson
but i already know people know and we're
talking about chicago because jake is
a chicago native which people probably
also know you can hear it in his voice
he's very chicago he talks about yeah
he's got this just a real chicago feel
and it reminds me of vince vaughn
another chicago i grew up outside
chicago
but jake is just one like vince i think
is remarkably funny i would suggest
he's sharp sharp quick i i would put him
up there with vince as among the
funniest people i've ever met people
with whom i just love doing bits with
laughing with jake is just the best i'm
gonna do new girl with him yeah jake was
the star of new girl and i had known him
a little bit before then but not well i
knew him through my friend john
a star yeah well this show's called new
girl yeah he is a star he's one of the
many he's a star now yeah but he wasn't
the star that's true that's true in fact
the first year it was on he was like
they didn't know what to do with jake
really he was like the i guess the
romantic love yeah kind of but um what a
great showcase that show became uh for
him and we'll get into that
oh he's in a great movie have you seen
him win at all the joe swanson so good
you know both of you like winning all
joe swanberries it's so good yeah it
really is it's like a throwback too
christian i've been watching um easy
riders ra raging bulls
it's hard for me to say the documentary
about 70s cinema
is it pretentious to call it cinema
uh i didn't think it was until you asked
that question but now i think it is it's
like i wouldn't say 80s cinema because
80s to me are more like kind of
accessible schlocky um not as like
artistic i guess you know what i think
is pretentious and i was guilty of this
the other day i was responding to an
evil i love 80s movies i was responding
to an email about um
the movie we made
and i was writing to one of the
producers and i forget exactly what the
context was but i referred to it in the
email
as a film and i sent the email and i
immediately
felt like a douche yeah it's dude she
thought film it's a movie yeah i mean
there are films there are films and then
there are a movie yeah we didn't make a
film paul thomas anderson makes films
yes
we made a movie we made he does have a
lot of fart jokes in his films
um
but we're excited for people to see our
movie
uh coming out soon hopefully we just saw
trailer for it's exciting um anyway
jake is not in our movie but jake is in
a really great film called win it all
and drinking buddies is so good so good
jake was smart he did a lot of drinking
buddies about it takes place in a bar
he's with olivia wilde um he's not
drinking bud light seltzer in it but he
is drinking beer hey nice
yes speaking of uh you know why not
whoa wow why not
um
let's hear it all right let's hear it
you're going to enjoy your bud light
seltzer while i enjoy listening to this
interview life could be a dream
sweetheart
hello hello again you're booming over
we'll meet again
[Music]
hey buddy oh wait now i can't hear you
you think you're old
look at us
[Laughter]
my favorite was hearing you
uh through michelle's phone going
i think i'm on can you re-send it
[Laughter]
it reminded me when uh computers just
started taking off watching my dad do
things on like email
yeah he's gotten better but he was so
comedically bad he would point at his
little computer
say everything out loud he'd go like
i'd be like hey buddy just
move back and be normal
my brother my brother and i used to do a
game with my dad that i think you would
get a kick out of but i just remember
my dad's a guy you know he spent so many
years of his life partying so hard
he did oh yeah he was like
alcohol drugs sold cars party guy so
there's just a big part of his brain
that unfortunately is is you know a
little bit fried yeah yeah we're all
close now we're all buddies but so when
we all first started becoming buds it
would be my brother my dad and i and my
brother and i are clowns
and so we would text each other words
while we were together to try to get my
dad to say
justin it was the hardest i've ever
laughed because you'd go
my brother would text me like
watermelon and i'm like watermelon so
i'd go hey dad and we'd be watching tv
and you'd go yeah and i'll go what's
that
big fruit the biggest fruit you could
think of and you'll go
cantaloupe and i go nah nah nah pink
inside with seeds and you go
watermelon
look at my brother and my brother would
go like this and then i would write like
a bucket of kittens and my brother would
right look look at me like too hard and
i'm like we're not gonna get there and
then he would go
dad what would you do if you what are a
bunch of baby cat names those are called
kittens
what if you put them in a what would you
call like a big thing you throw like
paint brushes in a bucket what if you
put those two together you can't just
block it what if you flipped it bucket
of kittens
hours and i know you and your brother
are close
and siblings form obviously their own
really weird annoying language
and my brother and i do so many bits
that any third person
is not only out but they're 500 miles
out it's like sometimes we literally
don't have to use words
like they're no longer inside jokes it's
like it's almost like it's inside
connection
it's a different language i've got i got
twin daughters and they're not identical
so they don't speak like people with
each other
but they do so many bits together
that i finally know what it's like to be
on the outside
oh funny yeah yeah and it's so much
better being on the inside yeah yeah
that's one of them one of them will say
to the other she'll be like
you know and she'll start laughing
i turn into that guy i go like guys i
don't see what's so funny
you're your dad and then what does that
mean
what's that and then they like smart
funnier yeah i know exactly
yeah it kind of sucks well it's like now
you're you're dead because some of the
funniest parts of that bit you did with
your brother and your dad is like is
your dad just guessing you know guessing
incorrectly and so there's also another
thing about becoming your parents which
and kids really humiliate you my
daughter and i were wrestling yesterday
and
she said to me she kind of jumped on me
and she said
you're so soft you're like a trampoline
and then she could tell that that
offended me and so she
and
it honestly hurt me in a way that
it took like i had to have a talk with
my wife about like she had to say like
jake you don't have women's boobs and
i'm like i know but like look at it from
this angle
you had to think about why it triggered
you why would a six-year-old say i had
women's boobs if i didn't kind of have
women's boobs well but i like that now
you're very you have uh a command of
them because when i met you i remember
you go hey eyes up here
well you know i wasn't wearing a bra at
the time right that's right it's sort of
your fault
you flogged them they were flopping
around you can't complain about it if
you're gonna flaunt them speaking of man
bros i was watching a bunch of stuff on
jerry stiller obviously with him passing
away
holy [ __ ] was that guy funny i was
watching his old seinfeld and then i i
read about it what really blew me away
is that yelling
and the way he did that character was
his choice
it was written as a meek might like he
there was another actor who played the
dad
and the mom you know the george
costanza's mom is so great i don't know
her name but yeah
yeah
she's so good and she was dominated and
the father was written as like
mild-mannered me
and they said they got that makes sense
they got a great actor to do it but the
problem was was she seemed mean rather
than funny and he seemed weak rather
than funny but they cast jerry stiller
and didn't give him a note to come back
and he said it was the second day of
shooting and his stuff wasn't working
so she was grilling him about yes son is
doing this and he just decided to yell
back it was you who did it
and larry david supposedly just went
like
keep doing that oh my god brilliant i
just love his relationship with kramer
not the best
certain partnerships like that are so
funny but what blows me away about a guy
like jerry stiller
and it's just a nice reminder you know
as we pursue this you know weird career
that no one gave him permission to do
that
that's no one said yeah
why was he yelling in this line
like he would have a line like i got to
go to the bathroom and he would just go
like i gotta go to the bathroom
imagine having the guts to do that oh my
god well that's it it's fearless it's
it's really fearless but that my
favorite outtakes are with uh julia
louis-dreyfus where she can't and then
the police station and then he's going
he's going you want a piece of me that
was the one you know yeah yes yeah and
and there are other there's something
else about jerry stiller in addition to
like the commitment and those funny
choices
there's something comedic looking about
him it's something as basic as he looks
really funny yeah yeah well he's got an
orange hair too
yes and
like a cartoonish face he looks like a
someone who would swindle you in the 20s
he's nearly perfect he's perfect yeah
man
what a lot and i've been thinking about
him and fred willard and
you know i've been watching a lot of
fred willard's stuff and like marveling
at it i just marvel at it i got to work
with him on new girl he played like a
cab driver i think and it was actually
tricky because and i kind of had a
thought after i went home that day
that there are certain comedic heroes i
don't need to work with like
fred willard for me was
what you know obviously somebody who
likes to improvise his work in guff in
uh the christopher guest movies is so
perfect yeah so working with them i
don't know it wasn't how i wanted it to
feel even though the scene worked there
are certain people i really just i'm
okay to be a fan of what was your big
break man because i remember watching
you with the vince vaughn stuff you did
early like bit parts and big movies
galaxy quest was my first thing big
thing that people saw
galaxy questions what was your first big
book though
uh i guess it was probably dodgeball it
was probably dodgeball yeah that was
2003. it's funny i was just watching the
breakup i didn't see the breakup in so
long and and i think of you as a chicago
well you're from chicago um
and he's so that's such a chicago movie
you know he's i really appreciated his
performance as a lead performance as a
both of them aniston and vince are so
[ __ ] good in that and i don't think i
i think it i think now that i've done a
few
you know
lead quote unquote lead romantic
whatever roles i think i have a newfound
appreciation and have been through
relationships that are complicated i
think i have a new appreciation of that
um
yeah what what was yours yours was a
fascination with second city right when
you were a kid yeah uh well first of all
vince vaughn had such a run as a killer
yeah there was a period of time he's the
same fred willard thing yeah i don't
necessarily ever need to be in a
scene improvising with vince vaughn
because swingers to me
was so hard funny him owen wilson will
ferrell that era
yeah i was so far from the business and
i thought those guys were so funny
it's funny you say that jay because i i
was thinking about you maybe because i
knew we were going to do this but i also
when i think of vince i think of you
both because you have similar voices but
um
but also similar instincts you have you
ha you're cut from
the same type of comedic cloth i think
and and i mean that in the best way like
i was thinking about what it would be
like to see you two together in a scene
and how
it might be too much it might be these
two i don't know i might uh you're also
both very giving as improv actors so you
might just be constantly setting one
another
if i'm in a scene with somebody who
wants to steamroll i'm happy to let him
go yeah because what happened what
happens to me is as soon as i'm on set
within a minute and a half i become the
first member of the audience so it's
like
for you for example when you did new
girl
your performance was to this day one of
the funniest things i've ever seen on a
set get out of it i'm here justin i'm
not kidding some of my favorite stuff of
yours is you setting people up and i
love it well because yeah it's i every
once in a while so your stuff on new
girl which
you're from you ginslinger had two
performances
the performance that the world saw on tv
which i'll be honest is pretty good it's
fine
and then their performance of ginslinger
that was on set which was
a
plus
home runs fireworks one of the greatest
comedic performances
i i gotta tell you i've ever seen oh man
unusable uh why wildly unusable
i mean justin do you remember do you
remember the bit when
so you were doing tons of improv and i
couldn't i couldn't stop laughing and
your character and zoe's character were
breaking up on like a some sort of porch
or something and for some reason my
character was in the scene but i don't
remember why
yeah but i didn't have any dialogue so i
was really just sitting there waiting
for you guys to finish the scene and we
all go home and you guys had some sweet
moment
your character had a line where you had
to say like like
i really really like care for you every
take you would say i really care for you
and then you'd go you too jess
[Laughter]
my memories of that my memories of that
were um
yeah like for working with zoe was fun
and i and i i kind of did it
because i was a fan of hers and um and
the second i was on set with you guys i
saw what you were doing i was like oh
[ __ ] i want to play with these guys this
is what i want to do so i i remember
there was i remember doing a scene at
the door with zoey where i go to pick
her up on a date it's a really like
nothing scenario i'm just like hey i'm
here
this is where you're going to say hi to
lamourne yes yeah so la morton's day was
winston i kept i thought it was so funny
to call him the wrong name every time
and
hey winstead or wilson or you know
and he'd correct me and i
and i was like i are you sure like i
think you might be wrong so funny but
something about you though justin that i
have never seen and i'm curious if it
came from the vince vaughn school or if
it's just you
going back to the jerry stiller in the
boldness when i take a chance and like
do an improv and
you know
the director in video village clearly
doesn't like it
justin
i always wilt away i shut down a little
bit
you you did that take
max screamfield myself and lamourne i
think we were scream laughing well
that's why i was encouraged i'm if
you're gonna say
how are you able to keep doing things
like that when the video video village
is clearly like okay we got that we got
you calling him winston's
it is singular
so just come in and say hi guys and then
you go like this hey guys winston's
[Laughter]
i remember zoe was trying to close the
door more because you guys were in the
background of that shot yeah and i would
i'd open the door really why to expose
you guys in the background just so i
could do say lines to you
i think they maybe included maybe one or
two lines of that stuff but but yeah the
stuff that we were doing there were so
many
there were so many hard laughs on that
show would you guys go through i
remember max telling me that
they would let you have the
the take where it's like just
blow the wheels off yeah well you know
so max who obviously is so funny what he
did
there which i really appreciate so when
the show started
you know i had come from the indie world
of indie films
and i thought when we were doing new
girl with jake kasdan and liz
merriweather and zoe dashanelle i
thought we were making freaks and geeks
and i thought we were doing the
ultra hip fox show
that was gonna get cancelled but the arc
i mean episode three i think my
character got cancer
yeah yeah do you know but for you know
lynn shelton directed it it was like
yeah
um you know these were
all people i had massive respect for and
i wanted to be in all their movies
miguel miguel miguel ortero
i see they only want me to do one
episode
[Laughter]
he's the best um
but so i i thought the tone of the show
was going to be
a different thing than max greenfield
did
so when the show started and he is in
tight underpants
like performing as if there's a live
studio audience he and i would have
talks
but not i mean we were buddies from the
start like we just we liked each other
yeah he would tell me
you are not in an indie sweetheart and
that would go
yeah sweetheart you're not in a multicam
and he was clearly winning and i was
losing we would both do a take
and then our showrunners would come out
and be like
bravo max bravo and then they'll go
really good jake really good uh can we
and then we had a scene where we had to
run outside by a garbage can and i was
clearly just struggling a little bit i
didn't know like it's just running
outside to throw something out
i did why are we on take 42
there's no
lines and max i'm opening the garbage i
rock out i throw it out i leave and then
max runs out like his pants are on fire
and everybody laughs let him have it
let's just move on and max goes i want
you to do a take where you pretend
there's a live studio audience watching
you
oh my god and he goes
let it be big baby let it be broad
so i literally did a take for max where
i ran out where i was like
and
you know they called cut our show
runners were laughing and
they were like great and i thought like
whoa so max
really wow he really helped me on that
show i gotta say the weird thing about
this era
and friends like you and me because i
was thinking about like you know when i
was gonna do this i was thinking about
you and i was thinking about max and i
was thinking about the you know the era
when we all met each other yeah i've
never hung out with max greenfield or
lamorin morris outside of work
not what not once
you're kidding at once
um that's a huge surprise i've never
hung out with dan owens junior outside
now mind you if we're shooting on
location we all go out to eat we all
like each other
yo yeah but the only time max and i had
ever gone out to eat max lamorie and i
was we were doing some photo shoot and
we all went and got a bite to eat and it
was a mistake
because
another table of people
saw the cast of new girl
doing bits with each other
but
they catch with it because i'll get
every once in a while people will say
like oh are you guys really great
friends and the truth is yes
yeah and i consider you a really good
friend but in this business we don't see
each other yeah i've got the friends who
i see on a regular basis and then i have
friends who i work with who i really
like
but the only time we see each other is
like this if max and i wanted to we'd
text all the time but if he tried to
facetime me on a wednesday i would write
like leave me alone
if he said this is for a podcast nobody
will watch i'll say wednesday at 10 30.
and i don't know why that is but like
you know this time yeah isn't that funny
i was like ooh jess i was like yeah i
want to i want to talk to justin so i
could schedule with like my wife and the
kids i got to go in the weird room i'm
going to be doing this thing
well now that we're scheduled i'm
excited if you said hey friend we
haven't talked for a while is wednesday
good i'm going to say like or whatever
day it is today
like back off weird i'm just gonna say
like no
what do you wanna talk about unless
you're sick i know i'm not gonna sit on
my computer and chitchat with you even
though i really like you i know well
also you have these responsibilities
that are uh you know the most pressing
res you have two kids you have a wife
you you're in quarantine i i imagine
it'd be a hard sell to say to your wife
hey uh honey i'm gonna take an hour well
here's and just check here's the real
truth
it wouldn't it would be a simple sell
it's not like when they say like you
know i'm in quarantine i'm with them all
the time i could say i'm going to go in
the room for an hour i just never think
to do it
it seems so odd to i know me too oh but
these podcasts and these you know are
such a fun or my favorite thing like
dana wayne's junior and i
we connected so strongly when we made
let's be cops
that the bond between me and him is so
weird
we are so comedically intimate via our
texts
but we've never met each other's kids
yeah
my wife will know if i'm texting with
damon because i will literally be going
like this while i text i'll be like
and she'll go is that damon and i'll go
yeah yeah oh yeah it is
what do your kids think of like what if
you ask them now what do you think
daddy's doing in terms of texting or of
you my career you just doing a podcast
and they get it now you know
the first weird one for my kids was
because when i did that tom cruise movie
we went to i brought my family with me
because oh all right because i don't do
you know having kids is such a trip in
terms of our careers because we have
such a clear path
you know when i was 17 and i realized i
wanted to be an actor
yeah everything you know even guys like
you and me who play like slacker dudes
if people knew how much we worked
right
it's like dude yeah are you like your
characters you mean like you know a guy
who sits around like no no pathetic i i
started grinding at 17. yeah i'm like
what i want to say to people who ask me
if i've worked hard look at my nose and
imagine it on tv
the amount of work i'm not the guy at
the mall who somebody's a talent scout
is like you they'll be like certain
actors they'll be like you know we saw
you know tom hardy and we knew
right nobody knew
jake's pointing to his nose nobody went
like
i saw that nose it was bent in four ways
and i thought let's have him disgust
women on tv
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wandery plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
but you were saying when you did the tom
cruise movie the mummy yeah that movie
was i gotta tell you it was so
intimidating to do
he's just the wildest guy on planet
earth that i've met yeah he really is
the wildest guy yeah when we met
we the first time we met i get an email
from alex kurtzman the director he wants
to do this movie i check in with olivia
wilde who we obviously both know i trust
her tastes i'm like what do you think of
kurtzman
she's like as nice as it gets
collaborative oh you're right they did
cowboys yeah cowboys and aliens yeah
yeah so i'm like okay so he's a nice guy
he's a good guy then i read the script
and there are 30 pages of stunts
and it's all me and tom cruise
and it's the first 25 pages of the movie
are me and him running around with
things exploded and i think like
now i know what this is going to be
he's going to want this all in a two
shot
and i don't want any of it in a two shot
there's one thing i love in this
business and that is when they say bring
in the stunt people
oh that's right that's right he does all
of his [ __ ] and i'm not somebody i'd
like you know and certain actors will be
like if it's a
a hand opening a door i want it to be my
hand i don't give a [ __ ]
if they wanted to use an old woman's
hand as mine
who cares yeah
so obviously tom cruise is the opposite
i fly out this is a true story no
exaggeration
so i have a change of heart i say yes to
kurtzman i read the script
i don't want to do it
too scary
am i a coward you bet your ass i am it
would be one thing i told my wife i'm
like if this happened seven years ago
when i was working at a casino yeah blow
my ass to mars
put a bottle rocket in my butt cheeks
light it up i need to eat but i'll let
you turn me into an actual mom i don't
care
yeah kick me in the face as hard as you
want
but at this point i had a job that i
knew was coming back for more years
uh-huh so i told my lawyer i was like i
think i'm out
and they said well after you kind of
said yes over the phone they had been
planning it to be you and tom i guess
got excited so if you're going to pass
you need to go meet him
oh boy
in like london
oh my god so to pass to pass so i'm in
the middle of production so they let me
off new girl on a friday
i leave thursday work i get on a plane
friday 12 hours i get off the plane and
i'm not a great sleeper i'm not i don't
go on a plane and i'm like i feel
amazing
when i get off a plane it's the same as
if a regular person was under a bridge
i'm like
partly i feel like i've been a prisoner
i've been in like this little box with
these people i've been watching all
kinds of weird [ __ ] had so much to drink
i also am a man of allergies so i'm like
[Laughter]
i get off the plane i'm also not going
to go to the bathroom on a plane
oh really you mean yes number number two
no i would take a [ __ ] on a plane i
won't piss on a plane
wait what
you're joking no
okay i won't i i will not take my my
penis out in a public bathroom
who cares you're able to [ __ ] you're
able to just take your butt out and not
yeah but i have like a little like
suction cup for my dick when i go looks
[Laughter]
um i haven't gone to the bathroom a
troll i get in the you know there's a
car service to pick me up i get in the
car and the guy's like
hey man how you doing i was like good
good and i go how far to the hotel
because at this point my hours are all
jacked i need to go to the bathroom i
need to shower i need to reset and he
goes oh we're not going to the hotel
we're going straight to the stage and i
said
why and he said per tom's request
justin i'm in cargo shorts
flip-flops with the airplane socks
i have like three sweatshirts on for no
reason like when you get cold in the
middle we we go straight to the sound
stage i meet tom oh god we go in a room
and we have a meeting that lasts
hours what do you talk about
he said right from the beginning he's
like i heard you're a little nervous
about the stunts and so he was doing a
lot of like
yeah like teasing but he's like do you
feel comfortable to walk up the stairs
i'm like okay i see how he's just
he's a super funny guy
yeah so he starts doing a lot of bits
before he's like are you comfortable to
sit on a couch or do you need a stunt
person for that and i'm like
i'm like all right i'm in a death trap
yeah also to be shamed by tom cruises
that's got it he's got to know that
words mind you the entire time i need to
go to the bathroom pretty intensely
but so we are then sitting there and
then how do you not immediately just go
okay i'm in london i'm already you kind
of did what happened with us was and
it's going back to the same thing that
basically happened in new girl which was
the turn which is you know it takes a
second to get your foot in and so at
first i was like trying to be really
like respectful and cool and being like
yeah totally oh we will shoot it like
that
and
you know i've never seen i'm not i
haven't seen a ton of movies i'm not a
film guy
i never watched those other mummies i've
never even seen most of the star wars
movies i don't care
no kidding it's just not for me
so me it's all about i'm having an
experience with this guy
and once i realized that i like him we
were about 45 minutes in and then i just
turned myself into
a fan and i went like
what was it like being in born on the
4th of july
and the funny thing about tom cruise
because i think he's been tom cruise so
long is he knows people kind of need to
do this
yeah but he was like
you know that was a really great movie
jake you thank you for asking you know
born on the f would answer and then i
would go what was
magnolia like you were awesome yeah
you're chris farley in the the chris
farley show and i and i was able to do
that for a while
and then i could be like
um also
i'd like
it's really cool sitting there man like
i watch your movies forever like you're
like a really good actor and he'd be
like thanks and i'll go
and then like it's really cool you like
got to know like action movies
and he's like
yeah hopefully we can do those together
and i'm like
yeah but i also think it's really weird
how risky you are and he's like
that guy told him i'm like
i heard about the mission impossible
thing when you're on the side of a plane
i'm not i don't want to do that i don't
want this to be a story of like
tom cruise and fellow actor
uh fall off a building and their heads
get smashed because i go in sweden
there's gonna be a big photo of you
there's not gonna be a big photo of the
fat guy from new girl next to you he
he's like jake i will insure you that
they will use your name in the obituary
i can promise you that that's not really
the explanation
but i gotta say i'm glad i did it
because he really was a joy to work with
and he's i've heard and he's a really
wild guy and part of the fun about our
business is every once in a while you
get to work with really wild people
who's the wildest person you've ever
worked with and not wild i don't mean
bad behave
i mean why wild wild
but not even i mean wild more like
when you look back on this weird career
you know there are certain people like i
used to work at a casino there are
certain people who hung out that casino
were just wild they are just different
than other humans
who was somebody you worked with that
while you were working with them you're
like you don't play the way other people
play you know who's like that i think is
amy sedaris
amy is she has she is wired in a way
that is just different than anyone i've
ever met and i love it i [ __ ]
and i don't even know if she this is the
best part about her i don't know if
she's aware of it right i hate to use
the word weird because it's like
overused but um but weird she's [ __ ]
weird
she's but in the best
she's great she's talented yeah i mean
but i know what you mean about tom
cruise i i think people think of think
of him he's done unhinged things or like
wild things publicly obviously but
but what they don't account for or they
don't i think pay enough respect to is
how weird he's capable of being in as an
actor but also in such a great way like
we were in uh
namibia
and we were shooting in the desert and
we were doing stunts and it was
hard [ __ ] work and he is in his mid
50s
and i was really beat up and i was
working out all the time we were like
jumping off of buildings and i knew he
must have been hurting
and you know we're on our 10 of a really
hard day
and we get word that the namibian film
council
had come for a photo opportunity with
tom cruise
he says yes we go over the film council
were
from a local tribe
they did not speak english
the lead of it spoke a little english
but it was very traditional like they
had like the traditional you know
clothes on it was a really unique
experience we're in the middle of the
african desert and when they see tom
they're all very excited when we first
meet them
it's very clear to me that english is
not their first language you know yeah
tom starts a little thank you speech
about how beautiful namibia is
and how much we will respect the land
how we will clean up after ourselves how
we will leave it better than we found it
justin he then starts getting into the
specific lenses he wanted to use to
highlight the beauty of namibia
he talks for over 30 minutes
get out of here he was one of the nicer
displays
oh my god i'm not convinced any of them
understood a word of what he was saying
[Laughter]
now
to them you could see on their faces
what an honor not only is tom cruise
coming to greet us
he is spending a lot of time yeah
he wasn't speaking gibberish what he was
saying was like it was as if he had
written the speech
there's moments of that speech if it was
filmed that i'm standing next to him i
am in awe then there's moments where i'm
like that's really true i've never
thought of direction like that
then there are moments i'm biting my
tongue so hard so i don't die laugh
because
hey man i don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on so did it end up being that
thing that you were afraid of uh
that that you were gonna have to keep up
with them that you were gonna have to
like do these things yeah well he said
so we were do we get to the uh
this set one day and we're in africa and
you know if they had built what looked
like a little town in the middle east
and you know it's about three stories
high
and some of them you know
they're like big buildings and skinny
ones and we need to run across it as the
insurgents are shooting at us
so i'm looking around for the wires
you know because like
it's it's high up
and
i could trip i don't know
i'm like looking at it we're walking
through it with wade eastman the stunt
coordinator and where the bombs are
going to go
cool and everybody's pretty confident
i think i literally was so in my head i
think i said on the day
you know i was like so out of body
experience having a panic attack but
trying to be cool and i'm like yeah
10 minutes before i shoot it and i'm
like on the day um
where will the wires be
and
he starts laughing yeah he starts
laughing
i mean there's if there was going to be
wires they would obviously have had to
already been established
where would they be hooked up to it's
just the sky this guy and i was like
i was like no no that makes perfect
sense that makes sense when i go
um
i go well my concern is um
if i were to fall off the building um
there does not seem to be a net and
you know i feel as if i would
potentially die
what i was waiting to hear is
of course there's going to be a net
some assurance like listen you're such a
[ __ ] goober
yeah you were hope you were waiting for
another laugh yeah like oh
we haven't seen the netting we need to
it's
and
instead what tom cruise said was well
don't fall
and
my
[ __ ]
tightened up
to such a degree
that it's never gone back to fully
normal
but it was like there was a couple of
moments like that on that movie with him
where i'm like well you really are a
different thing
yeah like different because i'm like we
looked at each other and he was laughing
and he said don't fall and then we like
walked to our first marks walked it
again
and then right beforehand he's like put
his hand on my shoulder he's like you
got this jake like this is why you've
been trying you're fine and i thought
like
holy [ __ ] i have to do this now and then
you just do it those are the moments
where you think
if you started a religion if he was like
i'm the savior i'm not yeah i mean
i join it next stop i guess not yeah
hey speaking of you want a piece of me
and was your brother at all was he did
he have any ambitions to be yeah well he
my brother is to this day the funniest
dude i've ever met he yeah you've talked
when we were growing up he was a we
always did bits and he used to do improv
in the city we grew up in the suburbs so
a huge memory for me once was when i was
a probably 14
my brother did like the coolest older
brother thing where he goes like
want to go to the city and see some
improv and i'm like absolutely and we
drove to this little theater in the city
and we parked and you know we walked in
and all like the performers knew my
brother which to me was oh wow
how much older was he he was a senior
when i was a freshman so he's four years
old 17
we were in the theater and right before
the show started the guy gets on stage
when he's about to go like does anybody
have a suggestion kind of moment and he
goes hey dan one of our uh favorite
students is here you want to perform
tonight bud and my brother goes like do
you care and i'm like
no
and my brother walked from the theater
onto the stage
murdered it oh wow
huge laughs then after he like walks
back to me and we like drive home
and i was sitting in the car like
i didn't know my brother had that
magical ability i didn't know people
like us
could get on stage
well it must have been sort of like when
superman came to earth like he had these
he didn't have extra special abilities
in on krypton right you know but because
so at home it was just like oh yeah he's
i you probably don't think of him as
being gifted well at home my brother the
fingers was my brother was always the
smarter adult he was like husband junior
and i was the fat spazzy little guy
if he were spayed i were farley
so it would be my brother's job to then
set something up so because i was the
baby i was always the fattest in the
family
and
i was always
the biggest spaz so in our family so in
our family
if there was like ice cream
and the bit was like who could eat it
all it was no question i was going to be
the one eating it all
and i always thought he and i would just
be doing some sort of two-man thing
together
and then
he got into politics and you know got
less interested and you know obviously
you know how long it takes to make money
and how much of a grind this business is
sure and you you were grinding for a
while right i know i started about 17 18
i got serious with this
and i had sketch shows improv shows i
was performing three four nights a week
i was a writer i went to nyu for uh play
writing and then i got i went to a year
of mfa for screenwriting
it was
anything and then when did you move to
la and why so
i was dating um do you know the uh the
playwright annie baker from new york oh
sure yeah i know annie annie was my
college girlfriend we dated first i
didn't know yeah we dated for four years
when we went to nyu together
oh my god yes so we were really serious
when she was 18 and i was 21 we dated
all throughout our early college
experience
and then we broke up and the breakup was
we were so codependent
that she said i just need to like
breathe a little so i went to chicago i
had um
my buddy billy bungaroff and i had an
idea
called project joke which was we were
going to tour the midwest and show what
it was like to perform in stand-up
places in like omaha
and i then went to oklahoma with a
writing partner and we were working on a
screenplay at the time he lived in
oklahoma so i lived on his couch
and his rich uncle
took us out one night
to give us like tough advice
you know and we had like so much to
drink and this guy was talking about how
he
made everything himself and me and him
are sitting on the couch working on a
screenplay and that's [ __ ] you gotta
work so i told him that i had an idea
that was ready to go we just didn't have
the money
and he goes how much do you need and i
said ten thousand dollars and this is no
bit the guy took out his checking
account and wrote me a check for ten
grand but i had totally lied and i
didn't have anything set up
i knew that was covered
i called my friend billy and i said like
i got 10 grand for project joke
and so we hired my sister to film us
uh we got on craigslist got a sound guy
we rented an rv we got my buddy who was
a musician in chicago to drive around i
called stand-up places all in the
midwest and pretended to be a manager
from snl so i booked this at like the
funny bone
uh oh my god all these different
comedy venues in minneapolis and omaha
iowa we did a tour and we wrote a show
in a week to show
what it was really like when i get on
stage
and i go like what's up omaha my name is
jake johnson uh this is the funny bone
it's a tuesday night and i am working on
some new material
and the way people would look at me
and bill would be like we don't want to
see you work [ __ ] out
so we had finished filming that and
annie and i had broken up
so
i was going to edit it and then i just
stayed in chicago lived with my dad he
and i had just started
forming our relationship that's right
for 17 years you hadn't really you
hadn't seen him i saw him every once in
a while you know he lived relatively
close he tried you know he had his
problems with addictions and i don't i
don't need to kick the man anymore
because we are genuinely close now uh
he's been sober for
25 years or something
oh wow
something insane wait jake tell me you
have this footage tell me yeah yeah oh
wow um but so long story short we were
in chicago and then annie and i were
officially breaking up and then a buddy
of mine called me up one day and said
that his roommate just left hollywood
and he could get me a room in his uh
apartment for 500 a month and he could
get me a job at a casino where i could
pay my rent
and i called that's right i forgot and i
called annie and i said like
are we gonna get back together kind of
thing and she told me that a guy had
just asked her on a date
and she's like i feel terrible to say
this but i want to go on the date
but she was cool like she didn't she
didn't lie to me yeah
yeah so i was and we were broken up
and this was in october
that this was all happening so i moved
there to l.a january 1st and then
within four months met
a bunch of my buddies i'm still friends
with who got me a commercial agent i
booked my first commercial made fifteen
thousand dollars and was hooked wow i
remember i'd see you in a lot of like
website web series stuff with michael
sarah like the mike sarah thing was a
crazy thing for my career because
i had i met mike at a party with seth
rogen and all those guys but it was
before those guys were massive it was
before super bad yeah so yeah i knew
them they were the freaks and geeks guys
and michael sarah was the guy from
arrested development
so i knew they were making some movies
super bad but it hadn't come out and
mike and i were at a party
and
we just started doing a bit because no
one knew me and i had a mustache and i
looked a little shady
was i would
in the conversation subtly ask if i
could live at their place for free
because you know like when you
when you have like an established group
of friends and there's somebody new it's
always the worst when that person stayed
somebody would be vouching for me they'd
be like nick jason novik would be like
jake's cool but then it'd be like me and
three people where
you know screenwriters or whatever so i
would just do like the yeah man like so
i've been out here for about a year
they'd be like how do you like it i'd be
like great man where do you live and
they'd be like i'm in west hollywood i
go
a studio or do you have multiple rooms
and they would go
uh yeah multiple rooms do you live with
like your family do you have kids
no i live alone like oh [ __ ] you got
like a couch
and you would watch people's faces
change so dramatically to just go like
this
is a disease
oh yeah i got a couch all right man it
was nice to talk to you and i go does it
pull out
yeah
mike's role
he improvises just like my brother
so i would say to mike you know i'd be
like wow big so you were on a tv show
for a lot of seasons he was like yeah
like you must have a pretty big place
you'd be like i guess i'd be like is
there a room where a guy like me could
like lay in a corner
you'd be like
you're not sleeping in my house
so
we just instantly played the same game
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
but what do you think what's your plan
man what's the strategy on the podcast
and is it just fun to be fun selfishly
too because i get to catch up with
people i mean kobe was max i you know i
get to talk to friends and like you said
i wouldn't i wouldn't make these plans
to just sit and talk times you know it's
great but um
we want to do another movie we had this
script that we loved about but it was
about a cop it was about a like a
xenophobic homophobic based on a
teamster that i knew once who was like
hey you wanna what are you doing now i
was like nothing he goes
you wanna get a beer
i go
oh
i go i get it no no you don't wanna get
a drink with a regular guy i get it you
know you're hot and so that's my
kryptonite so i was like oh no let's
buy you sushi every day for a week and a
half yeah so
we got wasted i mean the whole thing
literally
just
crazy yeah and uh and by the end he was
he got really weirdly emotional
and i want you know he wanted to be an
actor and he his father doesn't love him
i mean a lot of yeah it all came and the
next day when he came to pick me up it
was like it was like we had [ __ ] it
was like uh
hello you know you know
i gotta say it's first of all very funny
but yeah
i've really
stopped going out and getting drunk with
rants part of it is being recognized i
just don't go to bars the way i used to
it's not as fun no it's a different
beast but what i i'm really not sad
about it
because what started happening
once you hit like 35
when you go out and get drunk with
somebody your age and older
and they're a new friend
there's no good information that's
learned
right unless they're like old friends
like if you and i were in the same place
it would be a blast but still the third
person
who neither of us knew who worked on
your movie
you're like he's actually really nice
and i'd be like nice to meet you chad
yeah we there would be a point of the
evening chad would go you guys are cool
but can i tell you what i really think
and at this point in my life i'm just
saying like no
i know whatever you really think i don't
want to hear because i hate you now i
know i know i hate
that this sounds really cynical and
elitist but i
i don't remember the last time i went
out with a chad let's say and i was like
the next day i was like
oh man
i'm glad i did that that was [ __ ]
great speaking of and in terms of
getting to this era a little bit
something i'm genuinely excited about is
i feel like as a white guy of our
generation
there was a language white guys used to
be able to joke and say
that
more progressive people like myself at a
certain era in like the early 2000s
started going like
kind of gives me a stomachache
but
i don't know what to say because i've
always heard this type of joke yeah one
of the things i'm really excited about
this era and it started with me too
is now
guys like us it is our responsibility to
say to other guys like us
i don't think what you're saying is
funny i think it's hateful and i don't
want to be part of it yeah yeah but i
gotta say it's made
those random nights i go out so much
better because somebody will say one
little thing that will be not even
offensive but near it and i get to just
say before the night gets weird hey man
i'm not your guy for those bits right
right which i don't think they're funny
i'm not going to go down the road with
you
yeah i don't think you're being ironic
by saying them i don't think you're
being clever you're not lenny bruce so
shut your [ __ ] mouth and if that guy
thinks you're a dick so be it it's fine
he's gonna think i'm a dick anyhow it's
so true years ago i would have had to
entertain i would have had to humor that
guy's
shitty bit or joke or whatever it is and
i and in that sense i was complicit in
it but now yeah there's a nice freedom
in being able to be like not for me
yeah yeah who you were a huge you are
still a huge cubs fan you know honest to
god i become more of a fake sports fan
in the last few years oh oh really well
i was i was so diehard my whole life
sports used to mean and this sound makes
me feel like psychotic looking back
but i really believed that like the
projectory of certain players was also
mine
uh yeah like when the bulls drafted
derrick rose i was you know
really started my career and i thought
like
this is us
sports because i didn't grow up with a
dad
and it was not valued in my house at all
like it was a i was in a very female run
house
meaning on like monday night football
when we had one tv in our house
the bears were playing i wore the jersey
all day and my sister and my brother who
didn't care about sports
we used to divide up the tv by show
so
it would be like my sister gets to watch
blossom for 30 minutes
30 minutes of a football game and i'll
be like
this isn't how sports work and my mom
would be like what you think you get
three hours and i'd be like
yes the game
and i always as a kid fantasized about
my dad calling
and saying like why don't you watch the
game at my house oh wow so there was
always this thing about sports wow that
maybe he's going to have me watch with
him
and then when i was in chicago doing
that project joke thing and lived with
him
it was during the 2003 cub season
and we watched every game together wow
and everything that i wanted from my
youth with him i got wow
he was he watches sports exactly like me
my the thing that i wanted at 10 my
instinct was right he is the perfect guy
to watch sports with wow he's really
funny he's really into superstition so
he would say like
hey hey buddy hey buddy you gotta get
your left foot off the ground because
listen to me
when the innings started your left foot
was up and carry what struck out two
guys you put your left foot down and the
[ __ ] marlins doubled
and
you know when you can get into that and
believe it with somebody yeah you are
now part of their success so we would be
like you know what yesterday we were
eating ice cream bars in the third
inning and hugo i ordered 60 of them
every third inning we got ice cream bars
and we just had a blast yeah yeah and
then when i had kids i had daughters
sports is just not really a thing in my
house wow huh so like the games are on
and everybody knows that like daddy
likes the bears
so they'll come in and be like
and then after two minutes the boredom
on their face
oh my god if you don't like if you're
not into the game i can't imagine how
boring football must be and they they'll
try like you know my wife got him
jerseys when they were young and they'll
come in and they'll be like
taco tackle
and what ends up happening is i'm
sitting in a dark room by myself
watching a game that's weird
and i hear
my kids in the other room
and i just found myself going to them
more and then the less you watch and the
less you read
you if you miss one half a season
totally yeah now there's new players
right yeah so all of a sudden i just
don't know the people and if you don't
know the story i would never like in
terms of being a baseball fan
i would never go to a park and watch
strangers play the game of baseball
right well especially now jake the way
the teams are structured is they're
constantly moving around in free agency
when we were kids it was like
it was dead like singletary the same
people yeah
yeah you really solved it
have a career totally and then you you
would see like and then i got to know
some athletes like i met martellus
bennett the bears tight end yeah
and we went out to eat one day and we
became buds and
he was talking to me what it's like to
be a player and how
little you value the franchise oh yeah
i'm sure i'm sure because and i was as
he was saying it i'm like yeah totally
yeah when you look at it that way
through that lens you step back for
saying you're like this is ridiculous
they're all playing the same game they
just have different they're being paid
by a different company but if the bears
were owned by chicago yeah and if by
winning
that money was spread to low-income
neighborhood schools first right and i
knew like great the south side in the
west side that doesn't have the highest
tax property yeah
they get the money if the bears get to
the playoffs yeah they'll be like that's
really cool i really want the city of
chicago to beat the city of sacramento
no disrespect to sacramento but
sacramento is fine yeah [ __ ] sentimental
but that's not the case it's the
mccaskey family and the mccaskey family
is a family from the north suburbs that
have a ton of money right that's why you
start investigating when you get older
well who owns this team and and the
craft family and what did they do and
you get into the politics of the
ownership and the and then you try to
stay away from that to enjoy the game
right i don't want to right i say get
rid of the salary cap i want the players
to make so much money that if you play
the sport and destroy your body your
grandkids are rich right yeah it should
as it should really
a backup offense alignment is making 400
grand a year yeah so that's a lot of
money but 50 is taxed
they do have agents as well as they have
to pay for their own nutritionists and
they're on acupuncturists and they're on
massage therapists so now you're talking
about 150 000
for three years to last multiple lives
well that's what i thought was really
interesting among many things about the
last dance about scottie pippen taking
that deal
um
also the fact that they would
immediately vilify somebody the sec like
horus grant the second they left the
team you know and totally and embraced
somebody like dennis rodman whom they
had just hated it uh
it's tricky yeah and it's
it's alienated me in a way
from sports in that i still like sports
yeah um and i'm still you know excited
for
you know the game but i have become the
kind of fan that i used to hate i'm
thinking of the occasions when i'm in a
city when i'm not with my brother or a
friend and i'm sitting there i know what
that feels like to watch football by
yourself and you start thinking
i don't care that much it's fun to watch
i don't know if yeah i don't know if i
need to spend three hours on a sunday
morning yeah
because what will happen is my wife will
go like
yeah you know what we're thinking of
doing we're going to go to like
these blah blah blah gardens today and
then we're going to go get like pizza
and we might go do this thing that's
kind of fun with some friends and
i go like that sounds nice i trade that
you know the bears are playing the
jaguars at 10. so can i start meet up
with you guys at 1 30.
and then the catch is if you watch the
game and it's really boring and the
bears lose
i'm kind of in a bad mood yeah
so
it starts getting really weird if you go
like what happened well the [ __ ]
organization yeah and then you have to
unpack it through the lens of your kids
which is yes why is daddy in a bad mood
well because these other grown men
lost a game to another set of groups
other
grown men who are 15 years younger than
me right right right and the other thing
is is when an organization that you
cheer for like for example the bears
well i really wanted deshawn watson as
our question oh my god they passed over
him yeah now patrick mahones i didn't
know i don't watch college football but
i liked sean watson's story i was like i
think it would be good for the city of
chicago we've never had like our
quarterback like deshawn watson they're
calling him the his coach called him the
michael jordan of college football yeah
and that was incredible yeah it was
incredible and i was also i was like i
kind of want to look like like a cool
tatted up qb yeah i was sure we were
going to take deshaun watson when we
hear mitch trubisky out of north
carolina
and
i see this like guy who is a backup
there and i go
no disrespect to this human life which i
hope he i hope he has a great life yeah
but i googled him and at the time
the controversy was in college on
twitter he had tweeted
i think the direct quote was i like to
kiss titties
i didn't know that or like
kissing twitty titty's rules or
something both or which one's better but
some that was so like
just
a 20 year old shouldn't that go without
saying buddy i mean yeah you just keep
that inside and we all like kissing yeah
don't say that
don't say that um
but there was a moment where i
saw this controversy i saw him
another team got the guy i really
thought we were gonna get
i started trying to read and get excited
about mitch trubisky but i thought like
i i don't agree with the business
decision yeah this isn't what i wanted
for me the problem is is my dad is the
opposite right right and
the way he talks about sports
he did something that made me laugh so
hard we the bears meet used to mean a
ton lately it's faded for him but they
really meant a ton to him in his life
my brother lives in chicago my brother's
really close to him and the kids hang
out with him quite a bit oh that's cool
and my dad was talking to me about
he he called me to talk about a
frustration he had he wanted to talk it
out to see if he was in the wrong mm-hmm
and i go all right let's run through it
buddy and he goes
you know
i love dan i love kelly his wife i love
the family they've included me in i'm
very thankful
kelly is in a play my sister-in-law
she's an actress
it's in milwaukee which is about an hour
and a half drive they want me to go see
it on sunday
uh the matinee
i said is there any other day of the
week i could go i'll go saturday night
i'll go sunday they said this is the
show we want you to go to
jake
i had to tell him
it's the bear game dan doesn't
understand he said who cares
these are my dear friends i've known the
bears my whole life i only get to see
him 17 sundays a year
i've known these guys since i was a kid
is that what he said yeah he goes she's
scared
[ __ ] kiss he goes and i only get to see
my dear friends
17 sundays last month
i was crying
so you gotta tell dan why don't you tell
your wife and your family to [ __ ] off
i'm hanging out with my other family
your friends
my dear friends and the way he looks at
it and like he asked at a certain point
you know it's changed a little bit
recently but he said you know he got
sick years ago uh-huh and he said
if i die you know or when i die
i need you to scatter my ashes oh no
uh
wrigley feet no wrigley field and he
goes he does
you guys on the batter's box i'm a
righty scatter it there and he goes
this just in case ghosts are real
if you do that i'll haunt you right at
that moment
like it's a good thing like it's a well
like
favor well you know the conversation was
we were having one of these talks about
like you know what happens when you die
yeah and the both of us were like you
know because i believe that there's some
form of spirituality
but mostly with death it's so emotional
and sad that what you're hoping for is
to connect to somebody you really miss
by chance well my dad and i were talking
about it more scientifically yeah
especially at the time when we were
talking about this years ago
i could have a scientific conversation
with him
about ghosts
and the end-all be-all was if you die
and he's like oh well he's like we're
both saying it's probably just blackness
and no consciousness but he's like but
imagine if it wasn't
imagine if i die and i can see you but
you can't see me and i trying to i'm
saying jake jake and you don't hear and
i was like that would be a living
nightmare he's like let's do something
if that happens and you scatter it right
there
if i have any ability to contact you i'm
going to do it right then
oh my god i don't want this to happen i
don't want this happening certainly
anytime soon but
just imagine i'm there and then like the
lights go on that's the movie that's the
movie yeah
the reality is is i'm there nothing
helps but i like smell vodka his old
drink and be like good for him he waited
25 years
he gets to have a drink again
i gotta do a lightning round really
quick okay uh okay lightning round what
is your most commonly used emoji would
you say
um thumbs up i guess
yeah uh if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play
none
my body could i don't wouldn't want to
put my body through that
okay so women
yeah oh yes swimming season leisure yeah
leisurely swimming
floating you'd be a professional floater
hanging out in the pool
[Laughter]
uh if you could have one snack food for
the rest of your life what would it be
your go-to
back when you smoked french fries french
fries yeah you have a favorite movie or
one that you've been watching in
quarantine maybe that's like comforting
to you that you
i haven't been uh watching anything in
quarantine um zombies but you know
bottle rockets probably my favorite oh
yeah no kidding uh i could always go
back and watch that yeah and you find
new things
in it totally if you had to live
somewhere else where would it be
probably
uh rural california up in the mountains
okay uh north of north of mammoth like
near yosemite beautiful
um
uh if who's your favorite muppet do you
have a favorite muppet kermit kermit uh
if you'd have dinner with three people
dead or alive whom you've never met i
would want i would probably want to eat
with
common working people from wildly
different centuries so like
well they'd have to speak english
because it would be a nightmare to be
with somebody and be like be like the
tower of babel yeah yeah no communicator
so that limits me down are you enjoying
your meal
yeah like this is great like you're from
the fifth century and they go
so that would be a nightmare genghis
yeah well the funny thing about that
question is if you think about like if
somebody says that genghis khan like he
would murder you right right yeah i
think he wanted to eat with a hungry
tiger so the people i would want to eat
with for sure would have to one be
sissies right two
not be offended by the way i look or my
customs when i go like
right
all right let's skip it it's really
funny i wouldn't want to do anybody
overly famous because the worst would be
like it's like people were like abe
lincoln how boring would i be to abraham
he'd be like i've just been pulled from
heaven and then i'm like i did seven
years on the new girl uh the fox show
new girl i'm currently on stump town and
he's like
why would i have to talk to you for a
while well it's like how we started off
talking about the people we we
admire as actor you know like fred
willard it's like be careful
uh what you wish for um but could you
imagine pulling three people in the
middle of it two of them asked to go
back to heaven
einstein's like i was hanging out with
amelia earhart [ __ ] was going great what
am i doing i gotta tell you you are so
dumb yeah thank you mrs
i'd be too intimidated you're right i'd
be too intimidated if you have one
superpower what would it be
i don't know if you could be uh
reincarnated as an animal if that's what
the afterlife is gorilla gorilla
powerful vegetarian no question
oh wow jake just moved his camera to a
photo of a gorilla i almost said coco
you love gorillas
love them okay love them love
silverbacks man you really
i just love them you ever watch those
coco videos with the cat sure amazing
yeah uh
would you rather be called unattractive
or unfunny
i've been called both okay okay
which which which which golden girl do
you most identify with dorothy blanche
rose or sophia
uh the old one because supposedly she
was the youngest of the bunch yes yeah
but everybody thought she was sold and
since said been about 25 everybody in my
group of friends the joke is that i'm 60
or 50 as max would say something
happened with my something in my
personality happen where everybody
thinks i'm way older than them yeah but
isn't it like even the morn texts me
he'll write like he'll write like hey
dad are you uh i'm like i think i'm only
like five years older than you
but isn't that great because once you do
reach that age people are gonna be like
oh he's surprisingly young
uh he's younger than i thought
yeah uh do you do you prefer dogs or
cats i think i know this one
uh both i have a yeah i have an outdoor
cat i've never been a cat guy until this
cat we got peter but he's my favorite
pet i've ever oh cool
he's a feral cat we've had him for eight
years now when we move he moves with us
oh but in the last year he started
coming around and like looking for
cuddles and coming in the house
but he is
one of the strangest creatures i've ever
met
but he's like getting older now so it's
i have a lot of fun pretending to like
get in it with him yeah yeah
he's no street cat yeah but now peter's
getting quiet and we both the joke i
have with me and peter is we both really
don't want to reveal our true
personalities to our wife to aaron my
wife
because she thinks we're sweet and we
belong in the house so i'll be like
don't blow this peter shut your mouth
jake
don't you blow this for me
don't blow this shut your mouth pete uh
oh man i i i love you i'm i'm so glad we
got to do this thanks for taking the
time yeah i missed you guys
thank you thank the family for to let me
take you away oh for sure they're happy
all right buddy all right stay stay stay
safe
so that so that happened
oh offensive to chicago
um
oh my god that happened so it happened
i'm i'm blanking on the guy who played
his father on uh the real chicago actor
when i think of chicago actors i think
of that guy um dennis freyno dennis
farina oh yeah dennis farina played
jake's dad on uh new girl a new girl oh
really i love new girl i love doing the
show and i i really liked the show
watching it but um i stopped watching at
a certain point and i can't tell you why
it's not because i didn't like it it's
not a secret no you just don't know oh
no i'm not withholding anything from you
when you were talking to him about doing
the show and how you
would do all these takes knowing full
well that
they were unusable did you ever
think
maybe i'm annoying the higher-ups you
know what's interesting fox or
the producers you know what's
interesting is um
i should have and i didn't give a [ __ ]
because you're having such a good time
you know i hate saying this because it
sounds selfish and arrogant but um when
jake was describing that i i was having
these it was bringing back all these
memories of doing that and i don't
remember thinking oh maybe i'm pissing
people i think that though
i started censoring myself i started
like being more responsible
when zoe showed signs of being slightly
annoyed
because she is also my scene partner and
the last thing i want to do is alienate
my scene bar and be like disrespectful
it was disrespectful what i was doing
ultimately i was having fun jake and
lamar and i think those guys were having
fun right but in terms of like pissing
off the producers in the studio you know
i knew that it was such there was so
much money in that show it was such a
big budget thing yeah but it's also just
the time i know right it's people yeah
holding boom microphones
well
unless you you can make the argument
that they were enjoying well i i don't
want to speak for all of them but i know
some of them i'm sure they were i'm sure
they were it's like a break from the
script a little bit and but
i was blinded too by how much fun it was
how much fun we were having i just loved
playing with those guys it was like uh
it brought back such fond memories and
is this surprising that those two guys
don't hang out outside of this work
that was surprising and funny the way he
articulated it was like don't be weird
and facetime me
yeah but it's funny he said that like he
talked about never meeting up with
people
but by his energy and the amount he
was talking he was really dominating at
least the beginning of that conversation
it seemed like he was like unleashed
yes yeah well he was like why don't you
hang out with max greenfield i feel like
he has a lot of energy to get out well i
remember being around the two of them it
was uh i mean it was constant bits it
was like in between takes they were
there was no like going back to the
trailers and like napping it was like we
all had fun together in between those
setups and he clearly had a good time
catching up with you yeah and you know
it felt like a good excuse to hang out
with the guy and nothing against his
family i don't know his family but
there's a difference yeah you're hanging
out with your two young daughters and
your wife and like a guy this is the
kind of person jake is he's like i it's
just fun to like hang out and it's kind
of how he described ultimately deciding
to do the mummy
you know because he got to like tom
cruise he was just like he hung out with
that for a little bit so funny
i love how that tom cruise is if that is
a tactic that like
if you pass on something you have to
like come out and do it
knowing full well tom cruise knows full
well that he's so charming oh yeah that
no one would ever be able to say no to
him yeah good luck it's so funny i know
and i really painted a picture yeah
getting off that plane what a great
story in the cargo pants what a great
storyteller it wasn't that funny when he
was like at first i believed him that he
only pooped on planes and didn't i did
too he's cause he's so straight i did
too you're so dry
it's so funny well because i have a
thing you know that i don't like going
to the bathroom at all on planes i know
i hold it i know but unless you can pee
on planes only if it's an international
flight
i do not
um amazing even cross country that's a
six hour flight i don't think i ever
have i'll go like seven or eight times
on a cross country oh yeah i don't i
don't think i've ever that's why i
always like the window seat because i
know i'm never gonna bother anything i
don't poop
congratulations
proudly i don't i don't know if i have
i know someone and i'm not gonna name
who it is but his move on planes is to
is right when he gets on a plane is to
go poop i know what you're talking about
because he knows someone that's close to
us yeah because he knows that it's going
to be at the cleanest it's going to be
the entire time that's how different we
are from this person
but also that tom cruise thing
he i i
i like how he he
after he hustled so much he talked he
talked about how how hard he worked to
get where he got in in the business you
know yeah really really hustled oh yeah
and he finally was at a point where he
had this steady job on new girl and he
was a steady paycheck
and he was like i don't want to go
like do these crazy stunts and because
why should i i'm i'm finally comfortable
jake doesn't value being a star or b if
anything he looks down on that stuff but
he hustled enough to get foot in the
door totally to get comfortable and once
he was comfortable he's like i don't
need to do these crazy things i can do
this until tom cruise charms him the
consideration of being in a tom cruise
movie
had already been just like taken off the
table for him i think i i think it was
truly tom cruise's charm and his sense
of humor yeah the sports conversation
when he said like to this day he'll
watch a game and if his team loot if the
bears lose it like ruins his day he's a
bad mood afterwards and there's
something so nonsensical about that but
i completely i know relate to it that no
matter how how much you know mental
gymnastics you do to convince yourself i
know that it's ridiculous that it's just
guys wearing guys that you've never met
wearing a uniform and they play for
whoever paid them more yeah but you know
what's beautiful about what he said
about his dad about how
sports was something that that kind of
bonded him to his father only because he
that was absent in his life for so long
that made me feel
lucky to have
always had a dad who was there to watch
a game yeah you know yeah it was always
fun watching sports with paw
it is that's how we got into sports but
it's infuriating because he now it is
because he roots for
the patriots well i didn't tell you this
not anymore you know he said brady is
gone yeah yeah he's going to stop
rooting for the face you might like tom
brady more than i do
yeah wow maybe that's really good for
reasons though i hope he doesn't like
tom brady because of his face
like you do um uh i like his dinner with
historical sissies that he said
he's like i wanted to have dinner with
like like a working like working people
from back in the day but as long as they
were like sissies because i'm afraid for
my safety
and he doesn't have dinner with famous
people is i've never thought of it this
way it makes sense
he doesn't want to have dinner with
famous people because he doesn't want
them to think why am i having dinner
with this guy
it's so true i know you'd feel so uh
you'd feel so insignificant or like
you'd have to or pressure to be more
significantly more impressive you'd have
to sell yourself as an important person
to dinner with and that's not check it's
it that's why that question that's
really healing
of his personality yeah let's read a
letter okay
olivia yeah olivia gg yeah
subject
i love you show
uh slash what's your third brother like
slash would you rather oh hi christian
and justin i just started listening to
your podcast and i'm so happy to have it
in my life really i'm glad that i didn't
know about it before so now i have all
the episodes available to binge really
sweet
i've especially liked listening to the
quarantine check-ins we haven't done one
in a while
they make me they still exist though
that's true oh yeah that's right there's
close them yeah
yeah
glass half full they make me feel better
when i'm anxious about covid and it's
interesting slash bizarre to be
transported back to the past coveted
mindsets compared with where we are now
yeah that's true for example in one of
the earlier check-ins you guys talk
about how we you've just heard that
maybe you should be wearing masks oh my
god doesn't that seem like ancient
history it seems it seems weird to it's
going to be weird when we don't have to
wear masks no mouths and shins i
know i've gotten used to the way that
people look now i know this is very
superficial but i had a little flake of
skin on my nose that my pre-covered
instinct was to like oh i should get
that off to be presentable to be like
not as i have a little flaky skin on my
nose
and i thought oh wait a minute i'll be
wearing them it'll be covered up
hey
one of my favorite things about the show
is listening to you talk about your
childhood and or family and being
previous this is back to olivia it's not
me saying this
i know i understand and being privy to
sibling talk i'm the oldest of three
sisters and gets so much joy and comfort
from being able to talk and joke around
with them in a way that i can't with
anyone else i am so curious about your
third brother and how he fits into the
dynamic does he we should have him on i
don't know if he
damien i will say this is um
quite protective of his privacy because
he's a teacher
uh and even if he wasn't a teacher he's
still protective of his presence he but
he takes his job very seriously i feel
weird talking about him i know i feel
weird even saying that he takes this
practice i know well he's also
i know he's uh he's not
part of this show so
we shouldn't really be talking about him
but i think we can say very generally
about him
that he is
um to describe him he's very intelligent
he's very funny i would say
uh he is
he is some quirks he has some funny
questions he's quirky
he's like new a new guy he's like the
new guy yeah he's very
analytical um uh-huh he's but i i in
terms of the dynamic incredible writer
he's very intelligent i hate you're
right but see to not say stuff about him
makes it sound like he's like close to
mystery now i know he's great he also uh
our dynamic is is uh the three of us
have always been very close and
um we always have so much fun when we're
together yeah but it's it i will also
add that when we're the three of us are
together we adopt a different dynamic
you and i i think everyone does
everything we all revert back to our
childhood our childhood so in childhood
i was much closer to damien i think and
i was very quiet so i'm yeah i'm more
quiet one of the three of us
and damien was the oldest so he he kind
of controls yeah he controls the flow
yeah yeah
yeah there you go olivia yeah oh and
he's also that's how we know dr dave
kessler oh yeah best friends in the same
vein is back to olivia in the same vein
here's a would you rather which brother
would you oh boy have you read this no
you haven't read this who would you
which brother would you rather make out
with worse
worse have sex with what
oh i'm sorry which brother would you
rather watch have sex oh that's really
different okay sorry i remember that
your brain right there
which brother would you rather watch
have sex
yeah i i we can't answer i can't i we i
can't answer this i can't talk about it
we just got through saying we have to
protect that means
anonymity would you rather we can't talk
about it wait which brother would you
rather watch have sex have sex with
someone i can answer that i don't think
we should all right
what would you say
uh and then she said i would say i would
say i would rather
i would rather watch you have sex
don't look at me only because of
basically what you were just saying
about him is that he is much more
private and i've i've seen you
i've never seen you have sex thankfully
but i've seen you
uh amorous
with women before so i feel like i'm a
halfway to having seen you have sex so
what about you
i guess same i've seen you more amorous
than i've seen damien amorous so i'm
closer to having seen you have sex
back to olivia's and which brother would
you rather watch you having sex oh boy
i guess for those damien really yeah
and less judgmental no only because
right now i'm living with you so i feel
like we need to maintain as much of a um
as much privacy as we can get i feel
like that would be crossing a line
so i would rather damien watch me
now i
the thought of either of you watching me
is awful only because it's
it it kind of implies that you were
doing it voluntarily
i mean it was like a clockwork orange
situation where you're i've never seen
it you've never seen it no uh but i know
you're i know the reference
yeah when he's being forced to but see
it was violent it would be impossible if
i was in the room while you were having
sex it would be impossible for me not to
try to
[ __ ] with you
so like if you looked up from the bed
and i was in the corner going like this
christian's making a really weird face
not only would i
obviously not be able to complete you
know whatever amorous situation i was in
i don't know if i'd be able to do it for
a while afterwards it's an awful lot
thanks olivia
by the way back to the the letter she
says for all scenarios you only have to
watch slash be watched one time and you
know when you are being watched oh you
know when you're being watched yeah hey
thank god it's only once well thanks
olivia and then she she goes thank you
so much for your show thank you olivia
and i'm actually for as awful as that
was i'm glad that she was specific and
she got into the weeds of it
i think you used that expression a lot
in the weeds into the weeds and i don't
know if you always use it right i think
it's oh really i think it you use it as
just getting detailed
when i
think it's more of a pejorative thing
like i'm stuck in the minutia of this
topic i think it's always pejorative in
the weeds doesn't it sound pejorative
i'm in the weeds i don't maybe i'm wrong
shorties
okay
well um all right after that i need i
need some time to myself i'm gonna go
drink what are you gonna do and go drink
a bud light seltzer and not think about
you guys uh thanks olivia thanks uh to
my favorite favorite one of my favorite
people he's awesome he really is uh jake
and check out i was gonna plug something
for jake but i don't know that he
oh uh stumptown stumptown
and he's in uh the spiderverse oh man
that's a great one have you seen that
yeah yes so good uh if you haven't check
out new girl it's on netflix
um so thanks jake and uh god do i miss
him and those all the lamorn max shout
out future guest maybe yeah lemon zoe
future zoey yeah would be great uh it's
gonna happen okay and thanks to all you
listening
if you're still listening
genslinger out
yeah
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
uh you've been listening to life is
short life short is hosted by me justin
long it's co-hosted by a man who's
rolling his eyes it's remarkable that
you still don't know christian long in
addition to you megan monaco is a
producer on it senior producer is
michelle mieshlands
audio engineers sergio enriquez
executive producers are marshall louis
and hernan lopez for wondering stay safe
stay happy
[Music]
remember it's good yeah
you prefer the pineapple right i like
pineapple though i hope you guys are
enjoying those responsibly oh it's going
in louis missouri
why'd you just say that i just felt like
it
what about
anheuser-busch st louis missouri that's
where bud light filters headquartered
yeah but why'd you say it
because i associate them so it just
rolls off the top oh really it's like
it's like pavlovian response yeah
whenever you say or hear bud light
uh-huh you just say anhyzer push things
why do you think we wouldn't enjoy it
responsibly why'd you say that
you have a wild look in your eyes
i'm just excited try this try and you
have hummus in your mouth but
it's
it's really good i have one yesterday
cranberry yeah really good maybe the
best like most subtle flavor a rival's
black cherry it does refreshing this
might be my favorite
it's just the most subtle
fly just warmed my mouth i think
oh
you see that
and it was like little enough that
you're not sure now it's like
it's you certainly can't feel it in your
mouth but it's like it either didn't go
in or it's like in there and it's so
small that you're like well
it's just in there you know
i've had that sometimes every once in a
while like a tiny little bug goes up
your nose and you're like
oh it's perspective i i
you don't know what the bug's been
through but i he never imagined that
it must look crazy
just like
big white formations with like
sticky
chickpea mix on them
this cranberry is good
you